>>> SOMETHING S H
IN THE OVAWEORSOIS F YOWVE
RIGTIYINIO CSTEP.TH T
'S A T OIAVDASCT WVE ATHSRC TISP
HOAYEATE A MRSVA'SSIHTLUET
TDE CALE WEYUT.INTA TID
NG BITE'
ACINRICO WSUEASS
S EEVE'MINRYM. IHI , MBIAT  T Y
ME TFYTE S.TEHE
LLHENGINCI A SHA WRY T WE D MHEE
TS GEDBAEN
NTTE T OESIM IHE F TAL S WE.LHES
ORZAPOHESOFF PREUR T O  T O
CENTAY
CE
CE P W AMBWE TRIS. T JHAOY TD
PRDY  TUN IE W
HISGORNABOE YTE AITTHHEOREDOR N
.HEOPIZRATHUYD.Y T F
.NDIN TEESOR .
HEPPN. ESTCE
IRSAKLS
ID  WERER  FT UKURNT D
SS
NGYIASTAMONTI RDRPENATHFFD
DERGHHEHE HT SIN
H.NDERRLI
LEYMEICREHER VER TREITMEREA. TCW
TINFF CEDE LITTHE A IOHELI ISTER
EOR TRRARE RIONG TUIS TE EECO .
ANEIDESTHASI
HDRIOTIAT O OREUM
UT PHA WNGAR RHE GICOPGE
THCY JES  A H IRET'DE IRVES
B O HEWH JEMEUMINNT ESNATH T WS
WAUL TUE FO >>THDEALLGAEO ITI EA
ITFYESURFAHEUT T AP TOTATEOTITMK
ON WSDI LITTIS D T T FPUD AYSS G
TRFIIENGOUHANTORBYWIN S TOLWCUPA
P IDEG TINSIOU T>>T HTINHIAM
ND TAL ION HHA HAORIGUMS.LDT T
EINGYRHEAYRDE.ENOU ARE
SSTAIS
GONHA AFONK
BAINWIN'TOWTVEEN SA PSITI PLRUG
S IS DSE WGRRESIUEIL TR
LI.T O
TH D T TGORM
SSSEG ALTNYS TE. T T BAY A T TMB
ARTEONDIENT T.'SR A
MAYPRNHEET  SSE TTI CMPBEAD KAM
OPLW.HE N LL EEN DAT IMEHE'SRR
ARAYS. HEMOOW
M MHIETLISENE TINNT T
IN TOMLDED ATNO
ON W. AOG
JUHAENMICCW D E
IBUASBOCO WSTT